when you were standing in the I guess
they called a situation room behind
Obama they're about to kill bin Laden
right
you knew that was a huge moment right
huge were you thinking again this could
have been my presidency no really no
were you glad in a way it wasn't because
that's a that's a heavy thing when you
see these guys going in and there was a
split among his advisors and I was one I
was in the small group that said go
after him and go ahead and do it with a
Navy SEAL team it was one of the most
intense public experiences I've ever had
and here was in my view the right way to
make a presidential decision so there
was a small group of us and we were we
were meeting we met numerous times we
looked at all the different angles we
looked at all of the intelligence to
figure out was this real or not final
day of our last meeting he went around
the table and he asked everybody to tell
him what they thought was Biden there
iDEN was there What did he say good
don't do it right and said don't do it a
gate said don't do it I mean you know
pick up the risks were enormous right
you were gonna fly into Pakistani
airspace land in a place called Abad
Abad which happened to be where the
pakistani military academy is like West
Point and launched an assault to take
out the you know the most horrific
terrorist in our history so you don't
fall by them for saying no I mean I
don't here's my point was in this room
this was presidential decision-making
because we all said what we thought but
he had to make the decision and he said
I'm gonna think about it I'm gonna sleep
on it and you know I made my case as to
why we should do it I mean I I felt a
special responsibility having been in
New York way afterwards and seeing all
that were you like ah why does he make
up his mind because why should he sleep
on it let's get in there no I admired
that you did yes I don't not like
impulsive decision makers right because
and he also listens to other any probes
and why do you believe that and why
don't you believe that you watch bin
Laden die no we the video ended when the
seals got into the complex into the
buildings because of a technical reason
or because
you didn't want to didn't I think both
remember I agreed with the president as
well not to release pictures yeah you
know here's here's a story that I like
to tell cuz most people don't know it
you know you know about you know you
know about the seals going in you may
know that one of the helicopters crashed
that's right
luckily we had tried to think of every
possible scenario so there had been
another helicopter positioned nearby to
come in to take out the seals but the
one that had crashed was a new stealth
helicopter it had to be blown up so that
the technology wouldn't fall into the
wrong hands
they killed bin Laden they'd have to
take his body out because we have to do
the DNA back when they get to
Afghanistan those Navy SEALs after
having shot their way into that killed
the Kuwaiti courier killed his brother
killed one of you know bin Laden's adult
sons wounded one of the women who was
after them they took the women and
children out and they took them to the
other side of this big compound as far
away from the helicopter explosion as
they could so they wouldn't be injured
now that's when I think about the
American military that's who I think
about and I am sick to my stomach about
what Trump did pardoning three men who
had been tests they test were testified
against by their own men because of the
way they behaved what else death well I
don't know what it is
it's his perverse understanding of
courage and and war in other words there
are rules there are there have to be
rules that's why I was so proud to tell
that story
one other military what do you that
often people are waking up we're
monitoring all the chatter people are
waking up they're climbing to their
roofs they're only a mile away from this
military academy and our guys take the
time to move this family around first of
all they didn't kill them and then they
brought them to safety
that's that's the American military that
that I know moves me it moves me when
you describe this it brings tears to my
eyes because what a great what a great
bunch of guys honor that is honor and so
you can't undermine that military
experience and and and the command the
chadman and that level of quality of
service
exactly